that why is it a flawed argument is that
look i'm i'm not a trained journalist
and i prove it every single day but i
i'd like to think a more open-ended
question would be presented to baker
mayfield because i don't think it's a
flawed argument and i don't think it's
disrespectful to entertain the question
of whether or not the absence of a guy
who has been for a season and a half the
focal point of endless questions about
when are they going to get in the ball
how are they going to get in the ball
why aren't they getting in the ball that
that
guy being removed from the equation for
whatever reason may make it easier for
the quarterback to play especially when
we saw how well baker mayfield played
in a game where odell beckham jr exited
on the first pass that was thrown to him
and was intercepted well i mean listen i
i understand that you know odell's a
phenomenal football player and the stats
have not matched up and there is
pressure around the situation or at
least a lot of scrutiny and people
evaluating and putting under a
microscope and doing all that you know i
do think yes was there pressure on baker
mayfield last year and do i think he
felt that a little bit when he was
trying to throw to odell and you know
we've talked about he wants to he wants
to throw the ball great he wants to make
sure he's happy all those things yes but
i feel like they overcame that this year
i do you know and again yeah the game
was awesome the other day but you know
who's to say it wouldn't have been a lot
better if odell beckham jr was out there
mike you know we can't forget that
aspect as well and i think ultimately
they're trying to show great respect to
a guy who
i think is very well liked in the locker
room there too so they're being careful
there with what they say and they
realize that that guy has got a lot of
influence on what goes on in that locker
room people teammates they love him
giants browns it doesn't matter he is a
loved player that way and i think
there's a little bit of that too just
trying to squash it because they don't
want to
be in that disrespectful conversation
towards him even though i'm with you it
is perfectly
you know respectable to ask that and
wonder that
it'll be interesting to see how much he
chooses to be around this team dak
prescott
instantly back in the building in dallas
getting the covet 19 testing every
single day so he can go be around the
team whenever he wants to be as he
rehabs his broken ankle will obj be
around
for the browns as they continue this
playoff push which
frankly with or without him
10 games looks very very attainable it
would be a disappointment at this point
if they don't win 10 games this year
that and that's based on their schedule
and also based on what they've done so
far this year
so i i look i understand why
mayfield kevin stefanski also receiver
jarvis landry a close friend of
beckham's would say what they said
yesterday but i think when we look at
this from a football standpoint and we
understand that a weight has been
removed from the offense a pressure
point has been exercised from the
equation and baker mayfield can just go
out and play without worrying about you
know if we don't win
and i'm gonna have to deal with all this
odell beckham jr why didn't i get him
the ball more and he's gonna be talking
about getting the ball more and you just
go you can just go out and do your thing
now it reminds me of when and i think i
said this earlier in the week when
calvin johnson retired from the lions i
just noticed that matthew stafford was
playing a little more freely arguably
playing a little bit better because it's
no longer that extra
element of there's this guy out there
who is megatron and i must get the
football to him it's just the way every
offense should run chris throw the ball
to the open man no it is all the great
offenses that's what they do they do i
mean that's you know of course hey do
you design plays
for
our best player to be the first read and
throw them the ball that way yes you do
but you don't make it all about one guy
all the time every play now you call an
offense according to what defenses are
doing you know what you think will work
and then within those kind confines you
hope you can find some ways to you know
feature a guy a little bit and uh
you know they're not on offense like
that in cleveland that's not what they
do they're gonna like stefanski says
there's no favorites they don't care
it's run the ball run the ball hey play
action bootleg pass it's one two three
that's it that's the play it's simple we
don't care we'll move you guys around to
where sometimes you get to do this and
sometimes you get to do that uh and
that's not going to lead to big wide
receiver numbers it's not going to
change there in cleveland as far as
that's concerned under stefanski that's
not what he believes in that's not how
he runs his offense and you know we'll
see where it goes i still am going to
sit here and tell you that i think
it is not a good thing that obj is not
there i know there's a little pressure
there but he helps the run game and he
helps open up a lot of other stuff on
the football field and makes defenses
think twice a little bit about what they
want to do because he is still scary and
that was really his best value to the
team at this point
i will say this though
after they beat the cowboys and we saw
that great performance moto beckham jr
his lone great performance of the year
after that happened
i
i talked to kevin stefanski and he said
look i challenge myself
to get the ball to otto beckham jr early
in games well there were two games after
that
the
what would the next two games the colts
game and the steelers game right yeah
colts game didn't happen
steelers game didn't happen so i still
don't know what they were caught in
right with this how to properly use
slash placate obj
and now they look here's the thing if
they make it to the playoffs without him
the ground swell in cleveland is going
to be
get what you can and move on from it
yeah probably
the the argument will be even if even if
baker mayfield says it's disrespectful
to have the conversation now even if
jarvis landry says there's no way we're
better without him even if kevin
stefanski says there's no way we're
better without him if this team makes it
to the playoffs without him you're going
to have people who are insisting the
time has come to move on now you also
may have players in the locker room
saying that how good will be if we have
obj all year but there's going to be a
lot of pressure i think and his health
is going to be
the first factor in whether or not they
can actually pull off a trade or whether
or not they even want him back next year
and the contract becomes an issue as
well it gets very complicated that's the
thing about mid-season and later
acl tears it really affects the
timetable for the next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports